[موسيقى]
اسرتنا
ليله ليلى الشطوره ليلى
ليلى ليلى الشطوره
[موسيقى]
انا انا ليلى
الحلوى الشطوره
نادتني ماما وهي مسروره انا انا ليلى
الحلوه الشطوره
نادتني ماما وهي مسروره خذي مني كاكا يا
بنيه للجده اعطيها هديه وامشي في حذر يا
بنتي لا تسمعي ابدا اغربا قابلني الذئب في
طريقي وسالني ينتظر جوابه
يا ليلى الى اين الوجه يا حلوه يا احلى
صغاري يا ليلى الى اين الوجه يا حلوه يا
احلى صغاري قلت الى بيت الجده اعطيته
عنوانا ذهب سريعا وسبقني قد اخفى الجده
عني لبس ثيابها كي يتنكر ثم انتظر ليخدعني
قلت لها جده اهلا يا حبي الاحلى والاجمل
لمشاكلك اصبح متغير لا يبدو لي مثل الاول
لما هكذا اذناك طويله اسمع صوتك يا جميله
عيناك تبدو جاحده اراكي
وابنانك اكبر تتلالا
بلا حال
النجده ساعدوني مرعوبه
بالصوت العالي سمع الصياد
واتى في الحال ضرب الباكر عن راسه بعدها
طارده بفاسه شكرته ليلى عن فعله وتعلمت
الان الدرسه لن اتحدث للغرباء ووصايا ماما
لن انسى لن اتحدث للغرباء ووصايا ماما لن
انساه
ليله ليلى الشطوره ليلى
ليلى ليلى الشطوره ليلى